the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
today's lecture in today's lecture I
want to develop several more formulas
that will allow us to reach our goal of
differentiating everything so these are
derivative formulas and they come in two
flavors the first kind is specific so
some specific function we're giving the
derivative of and that would be for
example X to the N or 1 over X those are
the ones that we did a couple of
lectures ago and then there are general
formulas and the general ones don't
actually give you a formula for a
specific function but tell you something
like if you take two functions and add
them together their derivative is the
sum of the derivatives or if you
multiply by a constant for example so C
times u the derivative of that is C
times u prime where C is constant all
right so these kinds of formulas are
very useful both the specific and the
general kind for example they're needed
so we need both kinds for polynomials
and more generally pretty much any set
of formulas that we give you will give
you a few functions to start out with
and then you'll be able to generate lots
more by these general formulas
so today we want to concentrate on the
trig functions and so we have some spool
start out with some specific formulas
and they're going to be the formulas for
the derivative of the sine function and
the cosine function so that's what we'll
spend the first part of the lecture on
and at the same time I hope to get you
very used to dealing with trig functions
although that's something that you
should think of as a gradual process
alright so in order to calculate these
I'm going to start over here and just
start the calculation so here we go
let's check what happens with the sine
function so I take sine X plus Delta X I
subtract sine X and I divide by sorry
let's leave a little space there sine X
and divided by Delta X all right so this
is the difference quotient and
eventually I'm going to have to take the
limit as Delta X goes to 0 and there's
really only one thing we can do with
this to simplify it or change it and
that is to use the sum formula for the
sine function so that's this that's sine
X cosine Delta X plus
oh that's not what it is okay so what is
it
sine X sine Delta X okay good you
remember plus cosine no oh okay
so which is it okay all right let's take
a vote is it sine sine or is it sine
cosine okay so is this going to be
cosine all right all right you better
remember these formulas all right okay
it turns out that it's sine cosine all
right cosine sine so here we go
no you got to do X here sine Delta X all
right
so now there's lots of places to get
confused here and you're going to need
to make sure that you get it right all
right so we're going to put those in
parentheses here sine a plus B is sine a
coast B plus Coast a sine B all right
now that's what I did over here except
it was the letter X was a and the letter
B was Delta X right now that's just the
first part that's just this part of the
expression I still have to remember the
minus sign X that comes at the end minus
sine X and then I have to remember the
denominator which is Delta X okay
all right so now the next thing we're
going to do is we're going to try to
group the terms and the difficulty with
all such arguments is the following one
any tricky limit is basically 0 over 0
when you set Delta X equal to 0 if I set
Delta X equal to 0 this is sine X minus
sine X so it's a 0 over 0 term here we
have various things which are 0 in
various things which are nonzero
we must group the terms so that 0 stays
over 0 otherwise we're going to have no
hope if we get some 1 over 0 term we'll
get something meaningless in the limit
so I claim that the right thing to do
here is to notice I'll just point out
this one thing is that the when Delta X
goes to 0 this cosine of 0 is 1 so it
doesn't cancel unless we throw in this
extra sine term here so I'm going to use
this common factor and combine those
terms so this is really the only thing
that you're going to have to check in
this particular calculation so we have
the common factor of sine X and then
that multiplies something that will
cancel which is cosine Delta X minus 1
divided by Delta X that's the first term
and now what's left well there's a
cosine X that factors out and then the
other factor is sine Delta X over Delta
X ok now
does anyone remember from last time what
this thing goes to how many people say
one how many people say zero all right
it's zero that's my favorite number
all right zero it's the easiest number
to deal with so this goes to zero and
that's what happens as Delta X tends to
zero
now how about this one
this one goes to one my second favorite
number almost as easy to deal with as
zero and these things are picked for a
reason they're the simplest numbers to
deal with so all together this thing as
Delta X goes to zero goes to what I want
a single person to answer brave
volunteers all right right back there
cosign because this factor is zero it
cancels and this factor has a 1 so it's
cosine so it's cosine X all right so our
conclusion over here I'll put it in
orange is that the derivative of the
sine is the cosine all right okay now I
still want to label these very important
limit facts here this one we'll call a
and this one we're going to call B
because we haven't checked them yet I
promised you I would do that and I'll
have to do that this time so we're
relying on those things being true now
I'm going to do the same thing with the
cosine function except in order to do it
I'm going to have to remember the sum
rule for cosine so we're going to do
almost the same calculation here we're
going to see that that will work out but
now you have to remember the cosine of a
plus B is equal to cosine cosine no it's
not cosine squared because there are two
different quantities here's cosine a
cosine B - here's the minus sine sine a
sine B all right so you'll have to be
willing to call those forth at will
right now so okay so let's do the cosine
now so that's cosine X plus Delta X
minus cosine X divided by Delta X okay
there's the difference quotient for the
cosine function and now I'm going to do
the same thing I did before except I'm
going to apply the second rule that is
the sum rule for cosine and that's going
to give me cosine X cosine Delta X minus
sine X sine Delta X and then I have to
remember again to subtract the cosine
divided by this Delta X and now I'm
going to regroup just the way I did
before and I get the common factor of
cosine multiplying cosine Delta X minus
1 divided by Delta X and here I get the
sine X but actually it's minus sine X
and then I have sine Delta X divided by
Delta X all right the only difference is
this minus sign which I stuck inside
there well that's not the only
difference but it's a crucial difference
okay again by a we get that this is 0 as
Delta X tends to 0 and this is 1 those
are the properties I called a and B and
so the result here as Delta X tends to 0
is that we get negative sine X that's
the factor negative sine X all right so
this guy is negative sine X and I'll put
a little box around that too
all right now these formulas take a
little bit of getting used to and but
before I do that I'm going to explain to
you the proofs of a and B all right so
we'll we'll get ourselves started by
mentioning that now maybe maybe before I
do that though I want to show you how a
and B fit into the proofs of these
theorems so let me just make some
remarks here so this is just a remark
but it's meant to help you to frame how
these how these proofs worked so first
of all I want to point out that if you
take the rate of change of sign X now
let's start with cosign because it's
actually a little bit less obvious if I
take the rate of change of cosign X so
in other words this derivative at x
equals zero then by definition this is a
certain limit as Delta X goes to zero so
which one is it well I have to evaluate
cosine at 0 plus Delta X but that's just
Delta X and I have to subtract cosine at
0 that's the base point but that's just
1 and then I have to divide by Delta X
and lo and behold you can see that this
is exactly the limit that we had over
there this is the one that we know is
zero by what we call property a and
similarly if I take the derivative of
sine X at x equals zero then that's
going to be the limit as Delta X goes to
zero of sine Delta X over Delta X and
that's because I should be subtracting
sine of 0 but sine of zero is zero
all right so this is going to be won by
our property B and so the remark that I
want to make in addition to the two this
is something about the structure of
these two proofs which is the
derivatives of sine and cosine at x
equals 0 give all values of D by D X
sine X D by D X cosines so that's really
what this argument is showing us is that
we just need one rate of change at one
place and then we work out all the rest
of them all right so that that's that's
really the substance of this proof that
so of course really then shows that it
boils down to showing what this rate of
changes in these two cases and a equals
so now there's enough suspense that we
we want to make sure that we know that
those answers are correct I think looks
like erasers are over here
okay so let's let's demonstrate both of
them I'll start with B so I need to
figure out property B now we only have
one alternative as to a type of proof
that we can give of this kind of result
and that's because we only have one way
of describing sine and cosine functions
that is geometrically so we have to give
a geometric proof and to write down a
geometric proof we're gonna have to draw
a picture and the first step in the
proof really is to replace this variable
Delta X which is going to 0 with another
name which is suggestive of what we're
going to do which is the letter theta
for an angle okay so let's draw a
picture of what it is that we're going
to do here's the circle and here is the
origin and here's some little angle
well I'll draw it a little larger so
that it's visible here's theta all right
and this is the unit circle I won't
write that down on here but that's the
unit circle and now sine theta is this
vertical distance here maybe I'll draw
it in a different color so that we can
see it all ok so here's this distance so
this distance is sine theta ok now
almost the only other thing we have to
write down in this picture to have it
work out is that we have to recognize
that when theta is the angle that's also
the arc length of this piece of the
circle when measured in radians so this
length here is also arc length whoops
arc length theta that little piece in
there so maybe I'll use a different
color for that to indicate it so there's
orange and that's this this little chunk
there okay so those are the two pieces
now in order to to persuade you now that
the limit is what it's supposed to be
I'm going to extend the picture just a
little bit I'm going to double it just
for my own linguistic Sagan's so that I
can tell you a story alright so that
you'll remember this so I'm going to
take a theta angle below and I'll have
another copy of sine theta down here and
now the total picture is really like a
bow and it's bowstring there alright so
what we have here is a length of 2 sine
theta so maybe I'll write it this way 2
sine theta I just doubled it and here I
have underneath - whoops that's I got it
backwards sorry about that
trying to be fancy with the colored
chalk and I have it reversed here so
this is not 2 sine theta to the sine
theta is the vertical that's the green
so let's try that again this is 2 sine
theta all right and then in the
denominator I have the arc length which
is Theta is the first half and so double
it is 2 theta alright so if you like
this is the bow and up here we have the
bowstring
all right and of course that's we can
cancel the twos that's equal to sine
theta divided by theta and so now why
does this ten to one as theta goes to
goes to zero well it's because as the
angle theta gets very small this curved
piece looks more and more like a
straight one all right and if you get
very very close here the green segment
and the orange segment would just merge
they would be practically on top of each
other and they have closer and closer
and closer to the same length so that's
that's what that's why this is true
I guess I'll articulate that by saying
that a short curves are nearly straight
all right so that's the principle that
we're using or short pieces of curves if
you like are nearly straight so if you
like this is the principle so short
pieces of course all right so now I also
need to give you a proof of a and that
has to do with this cosine function here
this is this is the property a and so
I'm going to do this by flipping it
around because it turns out that this
numerator is a negative number if I want
to interpret it as a length I'm going to
want a positive quantity so I'm going to
write down 1 minus cosine theta here and
then I'm going to divide by theta there
all right again I'm going to make some
kind of interpretation now this time I'm
going to draw the same sort of bow and
arrow arrangement but maybe I'll
exaggerate it a little bit so here's the
vertex of the sector but will maybe make
it a little longer alright so here it is
and here was that middle line which was
the unit whoops okay I think I'm going
to have to tilt it up ok let's try from
here
all right well you know on your pencil
and paper it'll look better than it does
on my blackboard okay so here we are
here's this shape now this angle is
supposed to be theta and this angle is
another theta so here we have a length
which is again theta and another length
which is Theta over here that's the same
as in the other picture except we've
we've exaggerated a hit here and now we
have this vertical line which again I'm
going to draw in green the bowstring but
notice that as the vertex gets farther
and farther away the curved line gets
closer and closer to being a vertical
line that's sort of the flip side by
expansion of the the zoom in principle
the principle that that curves are
nearly straight when you zoom in if you
zoom out that would mean sending this
vertex way way out somewhere the curved
line the piece of the circle gets more
and more straight and now let me show
you where this numerator one minus
cosine theta is on this picture so where
is it it's well this whole distance is
one but the distance from the vertex to
the green is cosine of theta right
because this is theta so dropping down
the perpendicular this distance down
back to the origin is cosine theta so
this little tiny bitty segment here
which is basically the gap between the
curve and the vertical segment so the
gap is equal to one minus cosine Plato
right and so now you can see that as
this point gets farther away if this got
sent off to the Status Center you would
hardly be able to tell the difference
the bowstring would coincide with the
bow and this little gap between the
bowstring and the bow would be tending
to zero and that's the statement that
this tends to zero as theta test
the scaled version of that yeah question
down here ah the the question is doesn't
the denominator also ten to zero and the
answer is is yes in my strange analogy
here with zooming in what I did was I
zoomed out the picture so in other words
if you imagine so imagine you're you're
you're taking this and you're putting it
under a microscope over here and you're
looking at something where theta is
getting smaller and smaller and smaller
and smaller all right but now because I
want my picture I expanded my picture so
the ratio is the thing that's preserved
so if I if I make it so that this gap is
tiny now let me say this one more time
I'm afraid I've made life complicated
for myself if I simply let this theta
tendon to zero that would be the same
effect as making this closer and closer
in and then the vertical would approach
but I want to keep on blowing up the
picture so that I can see the difference
between the vertical and the curve so so
that's very much like if you're on a
video screening you zoom in zoom in zoom
in zoom in so the question is what would
that look like that is the same effect
as sending this point out farther and
farther in this in that direction in the
to the left and so I'm just trying to
visualize it for you by leaving the
theta at this scale but actually the
scale of the picture is then changing
when I do that so both theta theta is
going to 0 but I'm rescaling it so that
it's of a size that we can look at it
and then watching imagining what's
happening to it ok does that answer your
question
and that seems to prove that that limit
is equal to zero or zero
it proves more than it's equal to zero
over zero it's the ratio of this little
short thing to this longer thing and
this is getting much much shorter than
this total length you're absolutely
right that we're comparing two
quantities which are going to zero but
one of them is much smaller than the
other in the other case we compared two
quantities which are both going to zero
and they both end up being about equal
in length but here the the previous one
was this green line here it's this
little tiny bit here and it's waist
shorter than the than the two theta
distance all right or theta yeah another
question cos theta minus 1 over so so
here what I wrote is cosine Delta X
minus 1 divided by Delta X okay and I
claim that it goes to 0 here I wrote the
minus that that is that is cosine theta
a theta by Delta X by theta but then I
wrote this thing so cosine minus theta
minus 1 nice one isn't the negative of
this all right and if I show that this
goes to 0 it's the same as showing the
other one goes to 0 another question
so the question is what about this
business about arc length so the word
arc length that that shape that orange
shape is an arc and we're just talking
about the length of that arc and so
we're calling it arc length that's what
the word arc length mean it just means
the length of the arc why is this length
Theta okay so this is a very important
point in fact it's the very next point
that I wanted to make namely notice that
in this calculation it was very
important that we used length and that
means that the way that we're measuring
theta is in what are known as radians
all right so that applies to both B and
a it's it's a scaled change in a and
doesn't really matter but and B it's
very important the only way that this
orange length is the comparable to this
green length the vertical is comparable
to the arc is if we measure them in
terms of the same notion of length if we
measure them in degrees for example it
would be completely wrong we divide up
the angles into 360 degrees and that's
the wrong unit of measure the correct
measure is the length along the unit
circle which is what radians are and so
the only this is only true this is only
true here if we use radians all right so
again a little warning here that this is
in radians so now here X is in radians
and the formulas are just wrong if you
use other units yeah okay so the second
question is why is this crazy length
here one and the reason is that what I
did was the relationship between this
picture up here and this picture down
here is that I'm drawing a different
shape namely what I'm really imagining
here is a much much smaller theta okay
and then I'm blowing that up in scale so
this scale of this picture down here is
very different from the scale of the
picture up there and if if the angle is
very very very small then one has to be
very very long in order for me to finish
the circle so in other words this is
this length is one because I that's what
I'm insisting on so I'm claiming that
that's how I define this circle to be of
unit of radius another question
okay so the question is it's hard to
visualize this fact here okay so let me
let me take you through a couple of
steps all right because I think probably
other people are also having trouble
with this visualization the first part
of the visualization I'm going to try to
demonstrate on this picture up here the
first part of the visual ization is that
I should think of the beak of a bird
closing down getting narrower and
narrower so in other words theta has to
be getting the angle theta has to get
any smaller and smaller and smaller okay
that's the first step so that's the
process that we're talking about now in
order to draw that once theta gets
incredibly narrow in order to depict
that I have to blow the whole picture
back up in order to be able to see it
otherwise it just disappears on me in
fact in the limit theta equals zero it's
meaningless it's just a flat line that's
the whole problem with these tricky
limits is they're meaningless right at
the zero zero level it's only just a
little away that they're actually useful
that you get useful geometric
information out of them so we're just a
little away so that's what this picture
down below in Part A is meant to be it's
supposed to be that the theta is open a
tiny crack just a little bit and the
smallest I can draw it on the board
where you can visualize it is using the
whole length of the blackboard here for
that so I've opened a little tiny bit
and by the time we get to the other end
of the blackboard of course it's fairly
wide but this angle theta is a very
narrow is a very small angle all right
so so I'm trying to imagine what happens
as this collapses okay now when I
imagine that I have to imagine a
geometric interpretation of both the
numerator and the denominator of this
quantity here and just see what happens
now I claim the numerator is this little
tiny bit over here and the denominator
is
actually it's a half of this whole
length here but the factor of two
doesn't matter when you're seeing
whether something tends to zero or not
all right
and I claim if you stare at this it's
clear that this is much shorter than
that than that vertical curve there and
I'm claiming so this is what you have to
imagine is it as it gets smaller and
smaller and smaller still that has the
same effect of this thing going way way
WAY farther away and this vertical curve
getting closer and closer and closer to
the green and so that this gap between
them gets tiny and goes to zero all
right so not only does it go to zero
that's not enough for us but it also
goes to zero faster than this theta goes
to zero and that's what's over I hope
the evidence is pretty strong here
because it's so tiny already at this
stage all right we are going to move
forward and you'll have to ponder these
things some other time so I'm going to
give you an even harder thing to
visualize now so so be prepared okay
okay so now the next thing that I'd like
to do is to give you a second proof
because it really is important I think
to to understand this particular fact
more thoroughly and also to get a lot of
practice with sines and cosines so we're
going to give you I'm going to give you
a geometric proof of the formula for
sine here for the derivative of sine
so here we go this is a geometric proof
of this fact this is for all theta
alright so far we only did it for theta
equals zero and now we're going to do it
for all theta so this is a different
proof but it uses exactly the same
principles alright so I want to do this
by drawing another picture and the
picture is going to describe Y which is
sine theta which is the if you like the
vertical position of some some circular
motion so I'm imagining that some
something is going around in a circle
alright some particle is going around in
a circle and so here's the circle here's
the origin this is the unit distance and
right now it happens to be at this
location P all right maybe we'll put P a
little over here and here's the angle
theta all right and now we're going to
move it we're going to vary theta and
we're interested in the rate of change
of Y so Y is the height of P but we're
going to move it to another location
we'll move it along the circle to Q all
right so here it is here's the thing so
so how far did we move it well we moved
it by an angle Delta Theta
all right so we we started theta theta
is going to be fixed in this argument
we're going to move a little bit delta
theta and now we're just going to try to
figure out how far the thing moved well
in order to do that we've got to keep
track of the the height the vertical
displacement here so we're going to draw
this right angle here and this is the
position R and then this distance here
is the change in Y all right so the the
picture is we have something moving
around a unit circle a point moving
around a unit circle it starts at P it
moves to Q it moves from angle theta
angle theta plus Delta Theta and the
issue is how much does y move and the
formula for Y is sine theta so that's
kept telling us the rate of change of
sine theta
all right well so let's just try to
think a little bit about about what this
is so first of all I've already said
this I'm going to repeat it here Delta Y
is PR it's going from P and going
straight up to R that's how far Y moves
that's the change in Y that's what I
said up in the right-hand corner there
oops
I said PR but I wrote PQ huh all right
that's not a good idea
all right so Delta wise PR and now I
want to draw the diagram again one time
so here's Q here's R and here's P and
here's my triangle and now what I'd like
to do is draw this curve here which is
the piece of the arc of the circle but
really what I want to keep in mind is
something that I did also in all these
other arguments which is maybe I should
have called this orange but I'm going to
think of the straight line between so
it's the straight line approximation to
the curve that we're always interested
in so the straight line is much simpler
because that then we just have a
triangle here and in fact it's a right
triangle right so we have the geometry
of a right triangle which is going to
now let us do all of our calculations
okay so now the key step is this same
principle that we already used which is
that short pieces of curves are nearly
straight so that means that this piece
of the circular arc here from P to Q is
practically the same as the straight
segment from P to Q all right so that's
this principle that that well let's put
it over here is that PQ is it's
practically the same as the straight
segment
p2q so how are we going to to use that
well we want to use that quantitatively
in a following way what we want to is
that the distance from P to Q is
approximately Delta Theta right because
the arc length along that curve the
length of the curve is Delta Theta so
the length of the green which is PQ is
is almost Delta Theta so this is
essentially Delta Theta is this distance
here now the second step which is a
little trickier is that we have to work
out what this angle is so our goal I'm
going to put it one step below because
I'm going to put the geometric reasoning
in between is I need to figure out what
the angle QP R is if I can figure out
what this angle is then I'll be able to
figure out what this vertical distance
is because I'll know the hypotenuse and
I'll know the angle so I'll be able to
figure out what the side of the triangle
is so now let me show you why that's
possible to do so in order to do that
first of all I'm going to trade the
boards and show you where the line PQ is
so the line PQ is here that's the whole
thing and the key point about this line
that I need you to realize is that it's
practically perpendicular it's almost
perpendicular to this to this Ray here
all right it's not quite because because
of the distance between P to Q is
nonzero so it isn't quite but in a limit
it's going to be perpendicular exactly
perpendicular the tangent line to the
circle so the key thing that I'm going
to use
is that PQ is almost perpendicular to
Opie
alright the ray from the origin is
basically perpendicular to that green
line and then the second thing I'm going
to use is something that's obvious which
is that PR is vertical okay so those are
the two pieces of geometry that I need
to see and now notice what's happening
upstairs on the picture here in the
upper right what I have is that angle
theta is the angle between the
horizontal and opie that's angle theta
if I rotate it by 90 degrees the
horizontal becomes vertical it becomes
PR and the other thing rotated by 90
degrees becomes the Green Line so the
angle that I'm talking about I get by
taking this guy and rotating it by 90
degrees it's the same angle so that
means that this angle here is
essentially theta that's what this angle
is let me repeat that one more time we
started out with an angle that looks
like this which is the horizontal that's
the origin straight out horizontally
that's the thing that's labeled 1 that
distance there and then I also have the
my that's my right arm which is down
here my left arm is pointing up and it's
going from the origin to the point P so
here's the horizontal and they're in the
angle between them is Theta and now what
I claim is that if I rotate by 90
degrees up like this without changing
anything so that was what I did the
horizontal will become a vertical that's
PR that's going up PR and if I rotate Oh
P 90 degrees that's exactly PQ okay so
let me even well I think I will draw it
on there one time
see if you can let's do it with some
arrows here so I started out with this
and then we'll label this as let's see
label this is orange okay so red to
orange and then I rotate by 90 degrees
and the red becomes this starting from P
and the orange rotates around 90 degrees
and becomes this this thing here alright
so this angle here is the same as as the
other one which I've just drawn alright
different different or different origins
for the different vertices for the
angles okay well I didn't say that all
arguments were supposed to be easy
all right so I claim that the conclusion
is that this angle is approximately
theta and now we can finish our
calculation because we have something
with the hypotenuse being Delta Theta
and the angle being theta and so this
segment here PR is approximately the
hypotenuse length times the cosine of
the angle alright and that is exactly
what we wanted if we divide we divide by
Delta Theta we get Delta Y divided by
Delta theta is approximately cosine
theta alright and that's the same thing
as so what we want in the limit is
exactly the delta theta going to 0 of
Delta Y over Delta theta is equal to
cosine theta so we get an approximation
on a scale that we can visualize and in
the limit the formula is exact okay so
that is a geometric argument for the
same result namely that the derivative
of sine is cosine yeah
you will have to you do some kinds of
geometric proofs sometimes when you
really need this is probably in 1802 so
you'll you'll you'll need to make
reasoning like this this is for example
the way that you actually develop the
theory of arc length and dealing with
Delta X's and Delta Y's is a common tool
all right I have I have one more thing
that I want to talk about today which is
some general rules and so I'm going to
we took a little bit more time than I
expected with this so what I'm going to
do is just tell you the rules and we'll
discuss them in a few days so let me
tell you the general rules so these were
the specific ones and here are some
general ones so the first one is called
the product rule and what it says is
that if you take the product of two
functions and differentiate them you get
the derivative of one time's the other
plus the other times the derivative over
the one now the way that you should
remember this and the way that I'll
carry out the proof is that you should
think of it as you change one at a time
and this is a very useful way of
thinking about differentiation when you
have things which depend on more than
one function so this is a this is a
general procedure the second formula
that I wanted to mention is called the
quotient rule and that says the
following that u divided by V Prime has
a formula as well and the formula is U
prime V minus UV prime divided by V
squared so this is our second formula
let me just mention and both of them are
extremely valuable and you'll use them
all the time this one of course only
works when V is not 0
all right so because we're out of time
we're not going to prove these today but
we will prove these next time and you're
definitely going to be responsible for
these kinds of proofs